de très jeunes et plutôt plus gentille
même si elle devient très très vite
hystérique et aussi folle que quand il
sera paysagé gabriel matzneff sur le
plateau d' apostrophes
en 1990 il vient présenter son livre mes
amours décomposé en réalité son journal
intime où il parle de ses relations
sexuelles avec des adolescentes parfois
très jeunes vous faites l'amour le matin
l'après midi le soir sans des chronos un
échange qui choque aujourd'hui mais qui
n'était pas si inhabituel dans le monde
littéraire exemple en 1967
roger peyrefitte vient de publier le
livre notre amour qui relate son
histoire avec un garçon de 12 ans ce
n'est pas son réflexion qu'un homme de
mots nage libre au public une pareille
confession
pas de quoi scandaliser les foules selon
la journaliste françoise giroud pour
être singulier aujourd'hui il faut dire
toutes sortes d'autres choses mais comme
vous l'avez dit exactement dans le monde
feutré des intellectuels parisiens de
l'après mai 68 il est interdit
d'interdire
pourtant déjà à cette époque la
pédophilie est interdite par la loi dans
le milieu universitaire aussi des tests
pédophiles émergent
il faudrait que l'enfant se libère avec
l'aide des adultes
il aurait une sexualité brimés
explications avec le professeur et
philosophe rené sherer la famille depuis
au moins un siècle
dit et de ce que la morale officielle
dit c'est à dire l'enfant n'a pas droit
à l'ass actualité c'est à dire au
plaisir dans le même cercle
d'intellectuels philosophe enseignant à
l'université libre de vincennes guy
hocquenghem aussi journaliste à
libération il imaginé l'amour en l'an
2000 qui ont parlé à venir qu'on soit
dans tout cas on peut dire qu'on espère
qui tend à une mixité croissante à des
relations de plus en plus mixtes
c'est-à-dire à des relations entre
enfants et adultes à les relations entre
gens de même sexe aussi bien que de sexe
différent entre gens de races
différentes également à chaque fois les
invités sur le plateau ne cille pas très
peu de réactions sur les conséquences
pour l'enfant
par réaction la plus notable celle de
denise bombardier écrivaine canadienne
lors de l'émission apostrophes avec
gabriel matzneff en 1990 moi monsieur
matzneff me semble pitoyable ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est que dans ce pays
la littérature entre guillemets c'est
d'animer à ce genre de confidences
quelques jours après cet échange madness
est de nouveau invité sur un plateau
avec son ami l'écrivain philippe sollers
qui le défend et va même jusqu'à accuser
denise bombardier d'être une
conservatrice soviétique qui impose la
censure la codah ce qu'on vient
d'entendre n'ont pas cédé on va encore
avoir un procès sa feria je dois je
répète la [ __ ] combien entendre et
canadiennes je crois qu ville et résonne
comme ça la télévision il faudra
vraiment attendre le milieu des années
90 pour que la télévision donne la
parole à ses enfants et se pose
clairement la question des conséquences
de tels actes
[Musique]